hello ladies and gentlemen this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show what you're about
to hear is part 3 of a three-part
conversation with Kevin Kelly co-founder
of Wired magazine best-selling author
all-around fascinating human being if
you didn't catch the first two parts you
might want to do that before venturing
in but if not no fear we answer a lot of
questions it's a conversation you can
pretty much dip in and dip out as you
like so if you don't mind your stories
it's more of a jigsaw puzzle then by all
means keep on listening so without
further ado please enjoy part three the
final part of the Tim Ferriss show with
Kevin Kelley and thank you for listening
at this altitude
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking too
perhaps
jump into some rapid-fire questions and
they don't have to even be rapid-fire
questions the questions will be rapid
the answers can be as short as long as
you'd like
wow what book or books have you do you
gift or have gifted the most to other
people outside of your own books there
is a short graphic novel by Daniel pink
called Junko uh-huh and it's career
council advice it's aimed at young
people it's a graphic novel it's a
cartoon basically and it's and young
people as trying to teach them how to be
become indispensable mm-hmm and I've
given that away to young people because
it's for me the best summary of again
it's not like how to become successful
it's how to become indispensable to
that's right it's Adventures of Johnny
Bunco or something like that yeah that's
right that's right I have that on my
bookshelf back in San Francisco in fact
yeah if you know a young person who is
just starting out hand in that book it's
very easy for them to read this graphic
novel it's non-threatening it's fun and
it'll give them some like five great
principles
or starting out and helping them kind of
orient themselves as they start working
in the working life for someone who's
facing a lot of the same questions let's
just say so you have graduates asking
the what should I do why am I here what
am I good at if we fast forward to say
for the sake of argument mid-30s right
people in middle age hitting that
particular point are there any books
that you would recommend they read well
there is a book that I'm recommending by
Cal Newport it's called so good that
can't ignore you mmm this changed my
mind because I had kind of bought into
the kind of New Age California dogma of
follow your bliss you know money will
follow
and he makes a really good argument and
convinced me that's actually not very
good advice that what you really want to
do is to master something and to use
your mastering of something as a way to
get to your passion so if you start with
just passion it's sort of paralyzing
because and I know this from my own kids
they have their a team they really don't
know what they're passionate about I
mean some people are lucky enough to
know mm-hmm a lot of people aren't so
this is this is a book for people who
don't kind of really know what they're
really excellent at don't really know
what they're passionate about and his
premise is that you master something
almost anything at all just something
you master and you use that mastery to
kind of move you into a place where you
can begin to have passion and that you
kind of keep recycling that the way you
find your passion is through mastery
rather than the other way around which
is people think that they're going to
get their mastery through passion and I
kind of believed that former you know
that Matt the passion would lead to
mastery but after thinking about it
looking at his examples in his argument
I'm pretty sure that for at least for
most people you can get to your passion
through mastery and that would also give
you a currency or a lever to you guys
and getting to that point exactly
excellent do you a favorite fiction book
yes Oh fantastic
I usually talk it was great yeah
shot to rhom
mm-hmm shutter on it might take me a way
to explain this but it's it's a one
author wrote one book this is very
autobiographical the premise of the book
and the author's life seems completely
incredulous and kind of almost Hollywood
ish but what you get from it and the
where it's set it's set in India sets in
the slum of India and you get a credibly
vivid immersive deep and in some ways
uplifting view of India and the
underworld in India and at that part of
Asia and the main protagonist is this
very interesting zen criminal he's sort
of a coyote trickster mmm blend of
someone who is you know he does bad
things but at the same time he's sorry
about it and he has a kind of a cosmic
perspective it's very very unusual but
it's a long book and I actually
recommend if people are gonna try to is
that you actually to get the audible
version listen to it mm-hmm
it runs like you know on and on but to
be one of those books you do you wish
will never end
and I'll just tell you the beginning of
it which is that and this is the true
part mm-hmm which is that the guy the
author became a bank robber in New
Zealand he was hooked on drugs started
robbing banks was eventually caught and
escaped from prison and made his way to
the slums of India where because he had
a medical kit he was treated as the
doctor got involved and hooked on drugs
in India I got involved with the Mafia
was put into prison
tortured left abandoned in Obon news and
even in there started writing a book
here we have to wrote this book they
ripped it up destroyed it he was
recruited found a guru and Afghani was
recruited in the moolaade gene was
fighting there his entire company was
wiped out I mean this that's just the
beginning that's like the first day
it's really interesting that you would
bring up Shantaram for those people who
haven't heard of Josh Waitzkin I also
had him on this podcast Josh was the
basis for searching for bobby fisher' at
the book in the movie world-class chess
player also a very deep soulful guy and
this is one of his favorite books as
well oh yeah you would you would love
Josh sometime I'll have to put you guys
in touch but any favorite documentaries
well now your you've asked the wrong
question ah I have a site called true
films for about ten years I have
reviewed the best documentaries and
actually have a book called true films
which is the 200 best documentaries that
you should see before oh my god no
kidding wow you have no idea how timing
this is so it's 2 TR Yui films films
okay and so I there are a couple of
films that I would say have sort of
universal appreciation like you know
they may have like a rating of 100 on
Rotten Tomatoes or something so the one
documentary that I think everybody I
know who've seen it has loved is man on
wire that's such a good movie
alright so it's it's just transcendent
it's just a beautiful movie it's basic
fact that this guy basically he's gonna
walk to Twin Towers I mean he the moment
was he was like 14 year old kid in
France was at a dentist office looking
at a magazine and he saw they were had
plans to build this Twin Tower in New
York and he saw those two twin towers
and he said I need to walk between him
he didn't know how to type walk the
towers had not been built
he was already planning listening and he
was filming himself the whole way yeah
so amazing okay and so he does it and
how he does is amazing so another great
documentary that I love because it's
very unusual among documentaries and
that it films the villain side of the
whole thing as well which is king of
calm I haven't this has been recommended
to me that I still have not seen this
movie king of Kong is about a guy who
becomes the video game arcade game king
of Kong he becomes the champion but he
basically competing against this cabal
of people who were trying to subvert him
and are doing all kinds of really
terrible things to stop it which was all
on film yeah and so here's this really
kind of Midwest really lovable guy and
you're rooting for him the whole time
while these really sleazy guys are
trying to take him down it's just I have
to watch that so that's the second one
the third one is one that's not so well
known but it's called state of mind
mm-hm and it's about the spectacles in
North Korea which these two filmmakers
had access to and they followed several
different young athletes who were
practicing for the spectacle and in
these spectacles of course what it is is
keyboard pixels you know they have these
like huge stadium sized things and
they're like a little robot so they're
cogs in this machine which is like
perfect so you can imagine like you know
like a picture that's made up of pixels
but every pixels actually is a little
boy or girl holding up a card colored
cards in sequence so these things move
which means that you know there's not a
pixel missing so I mean there's nobody
sick is like you know this you're not
allowed to be sick you can't make a
mistake at all and it's getting inside
of North Korea which turns out to be a
nationwide cult and I think that in 50
years when they're gone nobody will
believe that that was even possible and
this documentary will be here saying no
no no they really was a nationwide cult
and they really did believe this it
really is amazing just to see what's
going on there all right I know what I'm
doing for the next few days next few
evenings I could go on unfortunately
because I have a lot of them but go to
the shrew film I only review ones that
are great so I don't do awesome I just
say these are fantastic man all right
I've been looking for this I cannot
believe that I'm only learning this now
I'm kind of embarrassed about that when
you think of the word or hear the word
successful who's the first person who
comes to mind Jesus all right why would
you say that well there aren't that many
people who've left their mark as many
people in the world as he has I think
what he was up to what he was doing is
you know
fastly been twisted misunderstood
whatever word you want but nonetheless
what's remarkable is and here's a guy
who didn't write anything so I think
success is also overrated all right I'd
love you to elaborate on that greatness
is overrated a lot of you know I
mentioned big numbers which is but it's
more of the impact they had on people's
lives but I think we tend to have an
image of success that's somewhat been
skewed by you know our current media
it's like our sense of beauty and women
it's sort of like in terms of all
possibilities it's in a very small
narrow define it so it's kind of
ritualistic in a certain sense I think
our idea of success is often today it
means you know somebody who has a lot of
money or who has a lot of fame or who
has some of these other trappings which
we assigned but I think can be
successful in by being true to and kind
of being the most you that you could
possibly be and I think that's what I
think of as one of the things of Jesus
whether you take him it's just a
historical character or anything beyond
was was about he certainly wasn't
imitating anybody I mean put that way
mm-hmm I mean I think that's the the
great temptation that people have is
they want to be someone else which is
basically they want to be in someone
else's movie you know they want to be
the best rock star and there's so many
of those already that you can only wind
up imitating somebody in that in that
slot and I think to me the success is
like you make your own slot you have a
new slot that didn't exist before and I
think you know that's of course what
users and many others were doing but it
was they were kind of making making a
new slot and that's really hard to do
but I think that's what I choked up as
success is you've made a new slot what
is your new slot I mean I'm trying to
not make any assumptions here yeah or
what would be your slot well my flight
would be Kevin Kelly I mean that's the
whole thing it's not going to be like a
career or you would really ideally be
something that was
you had no no imitators I mean it would
be who you are and that's that is
success actually in some senses is you
didn't imitate anybody no one else
imitated you afterwards so you know in a
certain sense you have if you become an
adjective that's a good sign right so I
think success is actually you kind of
make your own path if they're calling
you a successful entrepreneur then to me
that's not the best kind of success hmm
because you're being confined to the
yeah right right you're in a category if
you could change one thing about
yourself what would it be
I could sing ah you would like to sing
yeah I seem to be unable to carry a tune
I can't remember when my wife can hear
something when she can just sing it back
you later
I could hear the same song I have here
at the same song and I couldn't tell you
three notes of it I'm sure because I'm a
Tim Ferriss fan I'm sure I could train
myself to be yeah I know I could but I
guess I haven't and it would be
something that I have to really work at
and I haven't been I have trouble
carrying a tune staying in tune
remembering a tune I love music and and
then I appreciate it but in terms of
actually singing and or play I don't
play an instrument so maybe I would say
a little easier for me that would be
something nice
have you taken lessons or attempted to
take lessons no I got it what's this so
just in the spirit of trade I've
recently started exploring hand drumming
with Jim Jim Bayes and different types
of drums if anyone out there can get me
a pan art hang I would really love to
hear from you those of you that will
mean nothing to most people are hearing
this the research that has piqued my
curiosity most recently and of course
you don't want to run out and just start
swallowing these things but there's a
common anti epilepsy drug called
valproate
which apparently has some implications
for opening a window for achieving
perfect pitch in mature adults
very fascinating stuff Wow so if I do if
I do any experiments with that I will I
will certainly report back well now that
you've talked about it not the drug part
but I did remember I did take one class
imagine the drums I took a one class
an adult summer camp which I highly
recommend if your kids go to camp you
should go with them and it was a steel
drum oh cool
course and I love that so like you I
think if I did take up news for me it
would be drums of some sort because of
that I seem to respond it to it and I
did pretty good for the for the intro
course on steel drumming I find
percussion to be so primal just
satisfied some type of need that
probably predates yes verbal
communication even certainly certainly
written notes is your inner cave
are there any particular let's just say
in the first two hours of your day any
particular morning rituals or habits you
have that when performed consistently
you find produce better days for you and
I'm leaving better days undefined on
purpose but I love studying mornings and
or what people do when they wake up what
time do you wake up are there any
particular habits or rituals that you
find contribute to better days yeah yeah
I'm a very good sleeper I don't sleep a
lot these days I get up at 7:30 and I
have some rituals but I don't vary them
enough maybe to to know whether they are
I'm not a morning person okay to begin
with you're not a morning person well I
mean well the fact that you don't vary
them is perfect anyway I can't tell
which is better but for better or worse
when the first things I do is I read the
paper version of the New York Times it's
kind of like a guess or what I call a
guilty pleasure I don't know whether
that makes me better and anything else I
do but I don't drink coffee or anything
this is sort of my it's a ritual and
when I'm not here I don't read it so
it's like I don't miss it but like if
I'm here it's like I got to do it I
don't know it's kind of weird is that
immediately after waking you read the
paper or is there anything just about
just kind of in my pajamas I walked out
to the front gate and I pick it up and I
read it I mean and I don't read all of
it I just kind of go through and
I usually don't even read the news part
I read the slower stuff mm-hmm
I'm not sure why now that you're asking
and that's it that's the entire ritual I
don't have the same thing for breakfast
or anything at that
it's just that morning hit do you do
anything throughout your day regularly
maybe it's before bed or anything else
that that most other people probably
don't do that's a good question
no really okay I have no special sauce
but you're very consistent you don't
your days seem to be yeah they're very
very wildly so that in and of itself
might be something that a lot of people
don't okay let's pick up two different
while I'm here in this studio I have a
lot of control over my time so what I do
during today is is greatly varied I'll
you know I do a lots of things for short
amounts of times and go into my workshop
I'll read actually read book sit down
and read books during the middle of day
I'll do a hike and bring my camera out
almost every day maybe that it's
something that most people don't do is
probably they probably aren't taking
pictures with a camera every day or
reading books in the middle of the day
for that man right exactly
well maybe that's true I guess how do
you choose your books ah that's that's a
paradox of choice problems for a lot of
a lot of people it is just like what do
you listen to next in music I think the
music becomes free and everybody has all
the music in the world but deciding what
you're going to listen to becomes the
thing you'll pay for and I been my
prediction about Amazon is that we're
soon gonna have like any book you want
for free Amazon Prime digital version of
it you can have it whenever you want but
you'll pay for us for the
recommendations that's a great point
that's a great point I have a network of
friends and I listen to lots of podcasts
so I get in from all over the place and
like probably you are at this point I
long ago decided that in terms of the
greater scheme of things the cost of
books really cheap and if I wanted a
book I would buy it right and the result
is I am right now speaking in a
two-story high library of books that I
have and I don't do the same with
digital books because I
he figured out that oh you know if I
purchase it before I'm reading it it's
not going anywhere it's just sitting
there so I shouldn't really purchase a
digital book until like five seconds
before I'm gonna read it I have exactly
the opposite have it because right
because it's like what is there the
whole point of Kindle is that you don't
have to have it until like you need it
so on the digital books I don't buy
anything until like I'm seconds away
from reading it then I'll get it but the
paper books I was near to the point of
actually digitizing getting rid of all
my paper books I was that close about
five years ago but then I had an
epiphany I went to the private library
and I realized that books were never as
cheap as they are today and never will
be as cheap and that there's some power
about having these things in paper
always available no batteries you know
never obsolete and that if you made a
library now you would never be able to
make some of these libraries in 50 years
and so I decided to keep and to kind of
cultivate this paper library as a you
know it's something that was going to be
very powerful in the future mm-hmm
I like that or at least I can use it as
a justification for keeping a lot of
paper books exactly so I get tips from
books from podcasts from blogs from
friends from Amazon recommendations
anywhere and whenever I hear someone
recommend a book I'll go and check it
out and then I'm fairly free in buying
it but which means that I read a lot of
really mediocre books that's part of my
job right that's cool tools the book
that we were just talking about which is
this catalog of possibilities that I
self-published that has oh I know 1500
you know maybe there's a couple hundred
books that are recommended but I
probably read thousands and thousands
and thousands of books in order to
select those so I see part of my job
reading through and I read a lot of
how-to most of the books I'm reading is
nonfiction and a lot of it is even
instructional stuff one you know how to
battle Stonewall how to do origami how
to send a satellite micro satellite into
space whatever it is it doesn't matter
I'll look at it and
I've seen tens of thousands if not
50,000 how-to books over my lifetime I
can spot a really good one but still
I'll read through the other ones in
order so that someone else doesn't have
to and I can recommend saying this is
the best book on building a tiny house
if you want to build a tiny house do you
when you read these books on origami or
Stonewall do you follow through and
attempt these projects or are you
evaluating it purely based on your
amassed experience of reading lots of
these types of instructional books no
actually so maybe one of the other
things that I don't do every day but one
of the things I do in general that maybe
everyone else is not doing is that I
have like a thousand hobbies I dabble in
things so I have built stone walls more
than one I have done origami I have made
beer I have made wine I have you know
whatever it is I I've tried to do these
things in my life and I continue to try
and do them I have homeschool my son I
have and so as much as possible this is
what might you know I was talking before
about my day its irregular in a sense
that I'm here and I have things but I'm
doing new things and I'm reading new
things all the time so I'm in my outside
you know I'll make a go-kart or will do
something that I haven't done before and
that's the basis for helping decide
about these books I don't have to be an
expert in them but I can know enough to
tell whether or not the information
they're telling me is useful
what odd project over the last year has
been the most fun let's start there for
you yeah well just the last couple of
months I finally built myself a real
workshop hmm and wish I could show to
you because well the cool things that
did it was you know if you go on to like
Uline or somewhere these container
businesses they have these racks of bins
so I filled an entire wall of hundreds
and hundreds of bins so it's so I can
organize stuff and I'm a big fan of Adam
Savage and he has he has a principle for
his workshops called first order access
which basically means that you don't
want to store things behind anything
everything has to be at the first level
so you
look and see it mm-hmm it has to be
within reach and set so you have to be
able to see everything that you have and
it's accessible you don't want things
hidden behind other things right so
that's part of what I was doing with
this workshop is this kind of first
order access and it's tremendously
powerful I mean I just the few days or
the weeks I've had working and it's just
transforms everything it's like I had
the same problem with my books for many
many years I had books like multiple
different bookshelves in the house it
had them in boxes I had them this and
that and moving everything to one
location into a library where there was
two stories I could see all my books
just transformed them and made it really
useful because I could find them just
really go and reach for them and the
same thing with I'm finding bringing it
to my tools which is that you want to
have things plugged in ready to go
labeled organized first order access and
it can make simple jobs really simple
instead of like you know the hours of
looking for something right gathering
all the tools and all the tools and also
cooking it's just like exactly yes
what's having like a manual
random-access memory right right you
have your meat someplace right in front
of you oh that's very cool
if there were one object manual project
building something that you think every
human should have the experience of
doing what would that be it's very easy
you need to build your own house shelter
and it's not that hard to do believe me
I actually I built my own house and your
house is amazing I not this house I mean
I actually built one from cutting down
the logs cutting down the trees in
upstate New York Wow and doing the stone
hers and you know I mean unfortunately I
don't recommend this we made like two by
fours from trees you don't want to do
that because it's a pain because you
know standard standard lumber is very
it's very good if they're off a little
quarter of an inch as they are with
rough sawn lumber it's just it's a mess
but nonetheless a large portion of the
people in the world have made their own
homes
Adobe rammed earth bamboo whatever it is
and like going back to what we were just
started off with even if you don't wind
up living in it it's empowering
to know that you can do it and if you do
wind up living in it I have a friend
Lloyd Kahn who built this magnificent
place in Bolinas that he built was
salvaged material from from scratch over
the many years it gives you the power to
alter it's so I believe that your house
should be an extension of you that
really definitely is another projection
so another way of and also going back to
where we're talking about and the way of
to discover who you are and discover
what you're good at and because a
well-designed house should really
reflect you and and what I've discovered
a lot people design houses and they have
this kind of imaginary fantasy idea
about themselves and what they're going
to do well you know whatever it is
they're going to have a swimming pool
well you know it's like they're never
going to use a swimming pool whatever it
is I mean very few people actually have
a very good sense of who they are and
what they're gonna use something for but
if you really study yourself and really
are honest and design something that
space can help you become successful in
the sense of making it a slot for you
making your own slot and it's another
it's both a kind of a byproduct of who
you are and also can help you be kind or
it works both ways I like that right
you're not just finding yourself you're
creating yourself exactly and that so
this is a larger philosophical question
but this is something I talk about a lot
in a very high dimensional space which
means like the space of many pending
possibilities the act of finding and the
act of creating are identical mm-hmm
there's no difference between
discovering something and inventing
something you could we could say that
philosophically you know Benjamin
Franklin invented electricity we could
say that Christopher Columbus invented
America we could say that discovery and
invention are the same so that
discovering yourself inventing yourself
is really the same things bring about
that process you have to do both at once
I really enjoy that last question if you
could give your let's say you can pick
the age either 15 or 20 year old self
one or a few pieces of advice what would
they be you don't have to
do everything yourself you can hire
people to do stuff hmm
I wish I had known that when I was
younger I wish that I had when I was 20
working for Whole Earth Catalog
I wish I'd known that I could have hired
a programmer to do something I could
have hired someone it took me a long
time to understand that and then
recently I've been really big on it
hiring people through Elance mm-hmm you
know because I came from a little bit of
kind of a duty or self I mean I made a
nature museum when I was 12 at a
chemistry lab they built myself you know
building the stuff and I had by in the
classroom but I had a whole chemistry
lab I had nature museums I did all this
stuff and I did it myself and then of
course in moving into the Whole Earth
Catalog which was a kind of a do to
yourself thing I really was a you know I
just talked about building my own house
well now I will hire professionals to
work and it just took me a long time to
realize that there's something about
being able to pay a professional to do
what they do really well it's not like a
weakness it's like it helps them I'm
happy they're happy we're all happy and
I can do a lot more now there's
certainly a pleasure in doing things
yourself and dabbling it but there's
also this other thing which I didn't
realize which is there's this leverage
that you get by hiring people who are
really good paying them fairly working
with them to amplify what it is that you
want to do and I wish I knew that when I
was younger that's a fantastic answer
and you you have if I remember correctly
an assistant and a researcher is it is
that still true yeah it's one in the
same person oh they are the same okay
yeah so I thought that at one point you
had believed that you needed those
people to be two separate people but you
were here here's what I was saying was
that it's very unusual to find one
person who can do both of those tasks
both of those tasks are often not found
the same person because there's you know
the hunting the researching that kind of
there's a hunter aspect to research
there's often found in a certain
personality and then they're kind of the
admin it's march of you know dirt train
kind of making sure things gardening a
little bit and so it's often rare to
find someone who can do both it's
possible was it luck that you happened
upon this particular individual that you
work with now or did you have a method
for was there a particular approach that
were it I found that the place where I
found that over the 14 years it had to
the place where I found that they were
more likely than not to have a
combination was librarians I loved it
that's fantast heard on notices on the
librarian mailing lists and stuff that's
fantastic I said last question this will
be last question is there any other
thoughts or advice you'd like to leave
with the listeners and then where would
you like people to find more from you
your writing anywhere else I would say
congratulations to the people who are
listening to the podcast I think
podcasts are this fantastic new medium
I'm spending a lot of time there I think
it's just really great we're in the
early days of where this would go I'm
really impressed by the power of this
medium to teach and to inform sometimes
to entertain again I'm thankful to you
Tim for having me on and having a chance
to gab here but the people who are
listening I think keep going listen to
more podcasts
try to go wide I know Tim mentions them
here and there
take a chance listen to some more so
that's one thing I would say and as far
as finding out more about me I lucked
out with a very easy website it's my
initials KK KK dot org
I have a very public email for past 25
years you can find it very easily on my
website if you want email directly I
have not outsourced that unlike other
people that I know and my writings and
books and whatnot are at dub dub KK org
cool tools is a book that I really
believe that each of you out there
should have it's on paper it's sort of
the best of the web
like cool tools which is been going on
for 11 years now where we review every
day one great tool there are only
positive reviews why waste your time on
anything but the best and tools in the
broadest sense of the word of things
that are useful whether it's Elance or a
book on how to do psychedelics or a book
on how to build a workshop or how to
build a house or how to hike around the
world I and others recommend the best
here with some great context and it's
printed on paper or available in Amazon
not so easily found in bookstores
because it's because it's huge I mean
it's like it's like five pounds weighs
is really really big and if you don't
find like 500 things in there you didn't
know about that you wish into a bet like
last year I I'll give you a money back
so enjoy that so that's that cool tools
or cool tools in Amazon excellent well
Kevin this has been a blast it always is
every time we chat I feel like we should
chat more so hopefully we'll get a
chance to spend some more time together
soon back in NorCal or somewhere else
or in China it's been a long time I
could get back I'm ready I'm heading
back to Japan again and I know that you
have lots of roots in Asia but um I go
there to renew my sense of the future
because they are you know they're
bulldozing the past as fast as it can
headed racing into the future so I want
to see what Asia has in store for us
because mathematically we don't count
anymore three billion Asians and you
know 300 million Americans what can you
say yes right study up folks
yep specialization is for insects I
think Heinlein so enjoy your time on
this planet and look broadly like like
Kevin said Kevin thank you so much I
will talk to you soon and have a
wonderful day I will talk to you soon
thanks for having me okay well bye
if you want more of the tim ferriss show
you can subscribe to the podcast on
itunes or goto for our blog comm where
you'll find an award-winning blog tons
of audio and video interview stories
with people like Warren Buffett and Mike
Shinoda from Lincoln Park the books plus
much much more follow tim on twitter at
twitter.com/dspacestv or on facebook at
facebook.com slash Tim Ferriss until
next time thanks for listening
you